[Music]
in real life
tangled news submitted by geo power a
woman is facing charges after striking
multiple people with a frying pan
whoa Jia wait why was it you pop do
power
Gio's are superior I guess I am writing
it someone's getting hit with the we got
caught up I didn't hear the title
because I was so happy that there was a
geo power somebody hit someone with a
friend yeah so he need to know and it
was a woman oh yeah woman power hey
we've been doing violated because she
was in the kitchen so long that's that's
actually pretty genius cuz I remember in
high school like everyone rolled around
with the baseball bat in the trunk of
the car
cuz when you into fights and stuff and
cops pull you over it's almost playing
baseball have not tried this weapon but
if you just have a frying pan which
causes probably the same amount of
damage I was just cooking officer you
know that you should do back in the day
they would like moms or like women would
have their iron in their purse and then
they would sleep I don't know I just
mean how do you think oh that's grandma
irons it's just literally a man yeah
peace I was like what is I when I first
saw it I was like what the how do you
use this handy heated stove like the old
school stove I don't know how to iron me
neither I just steam everything you know
my husband does all the ironing I didn't
even know how to work our laundry
machine what they call whatever I'm
right there with you girl I don't know
how to use that [ __ ] do you could I cook
yeah are you telling you where you dirty
clothes right
and iron net how do you split up the
tasks oh I don't know
you just do it don't want just for the
things I can't do he has to do that's
kind of how my relationship yeah yeah
it's like I suck at it so go and do it
for [ __ ] and my husband cooks so I'm
just so picky so I don't trust him to
cook but I'm like I don't want to learn
how to iron cuz I know that he'll do it
if I learn then I really lose that hurt
yeah that's true he's such a meticulous
dresser yes I love the way your irons
Seberg Oh Murr oh no he's a January baby
Capricorn Capricorn's very uh my new
ship um no that's more Virgo but maybe
he's a Virgo rising but wide enough Oh
like very domestic like they like a blur
very work oriented and then they like
their women to be very domestics Oh
beginning January n jammer well
beginning oh yeah I definitely know the
date you know I want there to be a crime
show where you're a detective
and you figured everything out they
stopped for Leo the detective medium
alright so this woman here definitely
Aries this happened in Pennsylvania of
course
yeah those [ __ ] pens what the
Penner's is that how they are they swing
fine they're Amish
I think the Amish are in Pennsylvania
they are yeah the gangbang with frying
pans yup he allowed you thank you yeah
so technology
I heard that they've been having money
troubles and they've been delivering
meth what I'd watch that man watch it on
by it's like breaking my to you
Amish the Amish yeah that's tight like
there were there riding their horse and
then they have a bunch of meth in the
back are you lying
check it out it's all vice Alexis called
tip you gap yeah
I kept of world fly that went is wrong I
can't I can't I can't tell you what were
the contents of the documentary because
all I saw was a thumbnail and a title
and it said the men and I like math
problem or some Mennonites are different
okay I know a lot about weird
what's a Mennonite they were bonnets the
rural part of Virginia so that's around
your neighborhood I could tell you
everything about the Crips okay two
blocks from where
Nipsey Hussle got shot oh no oh yeah
you're not potentiation
that's right it's always the brave non
LA why people that come in and in there
there's other places I'm just saying
damn like you're brave that's like one
of my buddies he bought a house right at
the edge of like what's then they it's
like South Central right so he had a
housewarming party and although I'm like
are you sure I don't know if I should go
there because when I was growing up as a
kid that was a murder everyday kind of
area so I was like oh okay well let's
give it a shot and I Drive over there
and I'm like wow this place has changed
yeah it's crazy yeah we like to play gun
shot or fireworks it's really hard in
the summer everyone sets a firework much
like you shouldn't do when you're in
that neighborhood thank you bye Mexican
people gave an oboe to my mom's blog has
it all the [ __ ] time those big bomb
ones that boom my if you're in the
neighborhood that sure there are
shootouts happening all the time you
should be respectful and courteous not
set up fireworks though I know I'm
already going on yeah we don't care so
anyway so this woman here her name is
Tosh key groom she's 32 years old she's
facing aggravated assault simple assault
and terroristic threats charges simple
assault yeah this is a simple assault so
she goes along with the frying pan room
she looks sorry you look sad she does
look sad my god I usually call
like the mugshots but she I see remorse
in her face yeah the eyebrows are like
going this way I already forgive her
police received word of a female suspect
and that she had struck multiple people
inside of her apartment building with
the frying pan
the two victims said that they were
struck multiple times no reason no they
were wearing high heels I [ __ ] know
it
heels
wait I'll that's worse than what you
would hit someone over the head with the
pan too huh cuz they should have a gun I
know right
so they're saying the two victims said
that they were struck multiple times in
the head arms and hands Buffalo was it a
cast iron they don't mention what kind
of my agency Harper she can only swing
once for the kind of like I'm done yeah
his arm day they said that police found
her seated on the front porch holding
the frying pan she turned herself in rid
of the weapon I forgave her going on
nope they caught her red-handed they
ordered her to drop the pan multiple
times she refused and attempted to
strike the police with the pan the pan
please holy Susan shooter at least a
cast iron skillet I'd probably try to
use it to protect myself with the
bullets like a [ __ ] I Love Lucy
episode tangled remember the movie yeah
Disney movie it's an animation Oh like a
bad guy gets hit with the frying pan
yeah because she gets the frying pan and
she just came
yeah Wow this woman they got like a big
[ __ ] did she give her reasoning for
hitting I don't have a reasoning that's
all you fellas upstairs oh yeah you had
to fill in the blanks you're a detective
Geo right there yeah yeah can I get a
different name cuz you conjunctive Joe
what am I agent G agent is don't just
the investigator
agent G dingy oh okay yeah agent G oh
when you bring together okay yeah and
then what is she she's the what psychic
Nikki that's not even a detective name
at all sorry
no but you're a psychic detective
detective detective psyche in a psychic
detective well everyone has well with
Bart he's not really like that
what like I can't put you through
forensic I don't know let's just
together in my mind
Bart supports a forensic scientist oh
yeah so I'm the guy that shows up on the
eating a sandwich mmm no what am i
you're just a reporter you're just a
reporter we're giving each other roles
yeah
okay okay okay but they're like but then
you guys start rumors go you got to do
that see that's got to be a party or
possible but I've jumped to conclusions
all the time that's why I'm detective
Joe so I better start seeing you making
up some [ __ ] all right I want you to
assume things about me and make me
offended that's what I want you to do
Joe did you smoke some crack yep
well we were in lunch break nope yes yes
he did just not on lunch I missed living
next to apartments though why well
sometimes just cuz it was weird rich
people thing to say next to apartments
no cuz it was always some sort of like
[ __ ] drama happening it was really
dope like I remember they would get
drunk at night and then you would hear
them like wrestling and stuff in the
front like lawn or whatever that's just
called the ghetto G oh yeah true I'll
trade you Geo and in the morning we
would all go to the lawn and then we
would like pick up like jewelry you know
what you should say not
pinata it's like a ghetto pinata lived
in multiple apartments and they're not
all like that
yeah I mean I think you have more fun in
the ghetto it's probably there was no
lawn first [ __ ] ghetto I told you
they would play basketball in the middle
of street get a [ __ ] white spray can
and then like like drawing the court
that's awesome that's ghetto yeah I love
that and then there's always like babies
running around and you're like where are
your parents on the corner my friend's
little brother was that baby of my
street he would just be [ __ ] walking
around in his diapers and it one day
he'll just have only a t-shirt all
walking around I'm like what are you
doing Frankie go back home mmm I don't
know I have this weird thing where I
don't see children I'm like anti child
so if there are children around I feel
like I just I'm like everyone's like you
need to have kids and I'm so it's like
on my blinders on go to Harry Potter oh
you don't exist there are dogs walking
around our neighborhood so much that one
time there was one who looked real
homeless we put him in our backyard and
do it next door is my dog like some male
dogs and he's a boy okay forget whereas
very open yeah yeah yeah next door we
use it Oh next door okay so we're like
oh we lost this dog we put him in our
backyard and they're like oh that's my
dog I just let him wander the streets of
South Central he'll make his way back
home like that is a ghetto thing to do
there's always a neighborhood dog that
would like hang out on the lawn but then
he'll go up to the other houses and then
at the end of the day they'll go home
and we don't give a [ __ ] about him like
I mean we care about him because they're
like our alarms but then if they get
sick or whatever we're like well they'll
figure it out I never never took any of
our dogs to the vet maybe he was sick so
they were like someone will take pity on
him pay his vet bills and send him home
yeah maybe mmm that's kind of genes idea
[Music]